you've always described yourself to me
and to just about everybody as a kid
from brooklyn that's where i am what
does that mean i think what it means is
rick i never forgot where i came from
and that's true to this minute i never
forgot
where i came from so i'm 85 years old
but i'm the kid from brooklyn and that's
what i brought to the
to the business being curious born to do
interviews huh right
i was born to be what i do i didn't go
to college
my brother did i'm walking down the
street
in new york and a friend introduces me
to james sermons
who was chief of staff announcers at cbs
wonderful man and i said to him i want
to get in the radio what should i do
and he said get down to miami and i
knocked on doors in a small station
w-a-h-r in miami beach
gave me a job i was a disc jockey
and on may 1st 1957
i started on the air and from that
moment when that light went on
and i told the audience it was my first
day
never never never lie the audience
i uh i found my
magic i've been in the media a long time
rt is one of the few channels doing news
rt does news this is my country greatest
show on earth
tell the truth
you